understand Donald Trump thought he was
like I'll play ball and I'll get done
what I want to get done and they were
like no no no no no you don't understand
you live under our boot you know they
they the the joke is you know as soon as
you win the election you sit down in the
Oval Office guy from the CIA sits down
and just hands them sits down to Mr
President opens a middle of folder and
then slides a picture of JFK right
across the table and says we'll be in
touch and then leaves right we get it we
get it Trump is the guy who was like
what is this I don't know what you're
showing me why are you showing me a
picture of this guy and they're like um
we're letting you know letting me know
what I don't get it
to intimidate doesn't understand what
I'm trying to say to him he's like look
we're going to secure the Border we're
shutting down the no Mr President we're
not yes we are I'm the bus and he
doesn't listen yeah so what I what do I
think is I when when Trump was running I
remember I was in DC Trump had a meeting
with a bunch of establishment
Republicans they did not want him the
Democrats want him to be the pi Piper
candidate Trump I think genuinely wants
to secure the borders bring jobs back
that goes against their agenda